I don't know if we are sounding an alarm
bell here I think we are we're cognizant
of the reality of the situation and I
think if just if you look at the
analysis here this is going to be a a
tough debate now many debates are tough
but this is going to be tough thing
there's no point and there's no point in
hiding taking away from that so let's
let's be realistic and let's be ready
for that process series of debates when
they start to occur the Prime Minister
has said no deal is better than a bad
deal why do you disagree with that
there's got to be a deal here I mean he
no a No Deal would it's clearly not to
be thought of it would take us down the
route of WTO I think that would have a
pretty negative effect on our economy a
bad deal I mean one has to look at the
definition of a deal I think I'm
prepared to accept that there may well
be elements of idea which are better
than other elements of it but to walk
away with with a no deal and just have
some form of Reliance and WTO without
potentially some form of transition
agreement during which a deal or better
deal could be negotiated I think would
be a pretty negative scenario for our
economy our business and quite frankly
our country so what would be so bad
about falling back on WTO rules WTO
rules are a baseline and I think I
recognize that but it's a baseline of
course linked to an average tariff of
about what five point three five point
four percent but you look within that
broad regime and of course there are
there are big winners and losers in
terms of sectors and one third look at
agriculture one could look at food and
drink for example the other big thing of
course is you you realign then on what
lack of equivalence lack of rules of
origin and then you're into a massive
set of of I fear administrative hurdles
and tha's lon as administrative hurdles
non-tariff barriers that I think we
categorize them as that I think would be
a great great downer for British
industry the financial services sector
has indicated it could survive with a
transition period of two to three years
why is a five year transition period
importance for manufacturers I think you
have to look at the process of
negotiation I think I think every one of
us would like a transition period that
is appropriate to the negotiation the
outcome of those negotiations and if
that were to be successful within two or
three years then I think so be it but I
think common sense and what one looks at
the complexity of this I take the view
may be its intuitive but this appears to
me or it feels to me about five years is
about right here now separately we've
had the GDP latest revision for the
final quarter of last year the
manufacturing sector looks in pretty
fine fettle at the moment it does the
manufacturing sector has performed well
and interestingly it has performed well
particularly in the second half of the
year and particularly in the final
quarter I think that said one of the
that one of the main many measures that
we and others look at is of course
investment and we are seeing a downside
be ticking down I'm not going to call it
a falling off but we are seeing just an
easing back an investment and if that
were to continue during the process of
this year then I would be concerned and
of course it's that link to ongoing
investment of course that's the key to
future future innovation and prosperity